on continue à en parler avec notre
invité Lucas au bain directeur de
recherche à l'IRIS et spécialiste de la
Russie bonjour à vous alors d'abord
est-ce qu'on sait si desserts ont déjà
rejoint les rangs de Wagner et que
risque-t-il
oui on sait que les serres ont déjà
rejoint les rondes Wagner notamment au
début du conflit
ukrainien en 2014 évidemment c'est
quelque chose qui est interdit par la
loi serbe et il risque potentiellement
d'être emprisonné puisque ça met en
difficulté la diplomatie de la Serbie
qui cherche notamment à mener une
politique
multidectorienne à la fois dirigée vers
la Russie mais aussi vers l'Union
européenne et l'Occident la Serbie est
connue pour son grand écart dans ses
positions proches de Poutine et en même
temps une candidature à l'Union
européenne qui traîne depuis plus de 10
ans maintenant comment les autorités
peuvent-elles se positionner désormais
en tout cas pour le moment ce qui se
passait c'était que le président Serbes
cherchait à la fois à obtenir on va dire
le beurre et l'argent du beurre c'est à
dire qu'il regardait à la fois à l'Est
et à l'Ouest il a par exemple en il y a
quelques mois signé justement un nouvel
accord avec gaz Prom pour justement
étendre les liens économiques entre la
Russie et la Serbie dans le même temps
il répond régulièrement que il
souhaiterait justement que la Serbie
rejoigne l'Union européenne pour autant
et c'est ça toute la problématique il
doit essayer de négocier avec sa propre
population qui elle est globalement
plutôt défiante finalement à l'égard de
l'Union européenne et plus largement de
l'OTAN et de l'Occident puisqu'il y a la
question du Kosovo qui revient assez
régulièrement et évidemment une partie
de la population serbe aimerait
récupérer ces territoires ces anciens
territoires de la Yougoslavie là où
effectivement
la Russie elle ne reconnaît pas le
Kosovo donc forcément il y a ces accords
là et en face on a l'Union européenne
qui globalement elle reconnaît
l'existence du Kosovo et du coup toute
cette problématique fait que le
président doit en permanence mener une
politique multidectorielle à la fois à
l'est et à l'ouest comme je le disais le
problème étant que actuellement la
Russie tente d'ingérer encore un peu
plus dans les affaires serres notamment
via le groupe Wagner et on peut tout à
fait imaginer que le président serbe du
coup va mettre le haut là encore un peu
plus et peut-être non pas couper ses
relations avec la Russie mais en tout
cas les ralentir légèrement voilà pour
la position de la Serbie qui reste
compliqué et complexe on comprend
concernant Wagner maintenant on sait
déjà que le groupe militaire russe
recrutait en Afrique recrutait en prison
le fait que Wagner recrute désormais en
Serbie dans des pays comme on disait
qu'il tente adhérer à l'Union européenne
qu'est-ce que ça dit également de de la
volonté de Wagner pour l'avenir
alors déjà ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que avant l'intervention avant
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie le
24 février dernier le groupe Wagner a
compté environ entre 5000 et 10000
soldats les estimations les services de
renseignement américain actuellement
parlent de à peu près 50000 soldats qui
feraient partie du groupe Wagner on sait
que justement ce groupe a énormément
recruté il y a quelques mois cela
notamment dans les prisons en Russie on
sait que ces effectifs du coup ont
augmenté et effectivement Vladimir
Poutine en difficulté sur le terrain qui
voit son armée reculer régulièrement
depuis le début de l'été dernier se
retrouve en difficulté fait appel à du
mercenariat privé le groupe Wagner en
tête de fil évidemment qui commence à
avoir de plus en plus disons de poids
politique et militaire sur le terrain en
Ukraine mais aussi sur le terrain
politique en Russie et ce que ça dit
c'est simplement que le pouvoir russe
est en est en ballon en ballotage
défavorable et qui doit faire appel à
tous les moyens mis à sa disposition y
compris des milices privées ministres
privés qui rappelent le sont interdites
en Russie merci beaucoup Lucas Aubin
docteur en géopolitique à l'iris et
auteur justement de votre dernier livre
géopolitique de la Russie qui est
apparaître aux éditions La Découverte
merci à vous voilà pour la situation sur
le terrain